when we analyzed a single particle
motion say we have an object which is
moving with momentum P then we have two
principles our Newton's second law told
us that the force on the object causes
the momentum to change and now what we
like to do is consider another principle
suppose we're looking at the some point
about s we'd like to show that the
torque about s is equal to the change in
angular momentum of the particle about s
so let's now investigate that well
recall that angular momentum is defined
to be about a point a vector s and will
indicate m to show that this is the
vector from s to where the object is
located cross the momentum of the object
and what we want to now calculate is the
time derivative of that quantity well
when you take the time derivative of a
vector product it's the product rule and
so there's two terms here its DRS M DT
cross p plus r sm cross DP DT now no
matter what the point s is the
derivative of the vector that's
measuring where s - the mass is is
always the velocity of the object so
that's the velocity and momentum is just
mass times the velocity and you can see
that that quantity is zero because a
vector direct product with its cross
product with itself is zero and this
second term
notice that we have DP DT in here and
it's always crucial to understand in
these calculations where the second law
comes in this is just our s and cross F
and recall that when we talked about the
torque on an object about the point s by
the action of say some force and so
suppose we had a force acting on this
object and that's going to call
the object to change its direction by
some amount Delta P then the torque by
definition is Rs and cross the force and
we see that that is exactly equal to the
change in angular momentum and so for a
single particle the torque about a point
s causes the angular momentum about that
point to change and this result will
generalize for a collection of particles
in a calculation that's very similar